DAVID: Good morning.
Today at Google we are delighted
to welcome Mr. Timothy Edgar.
Mr. Edgar is a former National
Security and Intelligence
official, cybersecurity
expert, privacy lawyer,
and civil liberties activist.
He joined the American
Civil Liberties Union
just before 9/11,
and spent five years
fighting in Congress against
abuses in the war on terror.
He then left the ACLU to try
to make a difference by going
inside America's growing
surveillance state,
and went on to advise the
George W. Bush and Obama
Administrations on privacy
issues and cybersecurity.
In 2013, he left government
for Brown University
to help launch its professional
cybersecurity degree program,
and he is now a senior
fellow at Brown's Watson
Institute of International
and Public Affairs.
He's here today to discuss
his new book titled
"Beyond Snowden: Privacy,
Mass Surveillance,
and the Struggle
to Reform the NSA."
Please join me in welcoming
Mr. Timothy Edgar to Google.
TIMOTHY EDGAR: Well, thank
you very much, David,
and thank you to
Google for having me
for this talk on privacy,
mass surveillance,
and the struggle
to reform the NSA.
And I'll be talking about my
new book, "Beyond Snowden."
And first I want to
start out with thoughts
about making a
difference, and what
it takes to make a difference
in our age of mass surveillance.
Now, I had a theory that I could
make a difference by working
within the surveillance
state, and I
tried to do that for a period
of about 2005, 2006, up to 2013.
And there was another person
inside the surveillance state
at that time who I
actually never met,
and he had a different idea
about how to make a difference.
His name was Edward Snowden.
And instead of working
within the surveillance state
to try to reform it from
the inside the way I did,
he decided to make this
extraordinary decision
to steal troves of
classified documents,
go off to China and then
Russia, and kind of blow up
the whole system.
So I want to talk a little
bit about which tactic worked
better, which was
more effective,
and then think about what
we can do going forward,
as the book is entitled
"Beyond Snowden."
So to not hide the ball, I'm
going to give you my conclusion
up front.
The results that I had
working within the system
were results that I'm proud of.
We made some significant
achievements.
We took some Bush Era, post 9/11
domestic surveillance programs,
or at least programs that
surveilled domestic data,
we put them under the
framework of the secret Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance
Court, briefed Congress on them.
We brought them
within, basically,
the framework of our Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act.
We also made some
important improvements
in oversight of those programs.
I worked personally
on those improvements
to create what I call a
middle way between purely
domestic surveillance, where
you have individual court
orders of wiretaps, and the
kind of foreign surveillance
the NSA does with
far less oversight.
We did something kind
of in the middle--
the prism and upstream
collection programs
you may have heard of--
and we designed the
oversight system for that.
But I have to admit, we really
missed the broader impact
of all of these mass
surveillance programs
on the privacy not only
of the United States,
but of the whole world.
And the reason that we
missed that broader impact
is that we were working within
a very outdated legal framework,
a framework that really is from
the analog age of the 1970s,
and the main goal of which is to
prevent abusive domestic spying
for political purposes.
It's not to safeguard
privacy in a global age
of mass surveillance.
So what were the results
that Edward Snowden
had in 2013 with his massive
revelations of NSA spying?
Well, four years later,
we can render somewhat
of a verdict on the results
of the Snowden revelations.
First, there was an absolute
revolution in transparency.
And we'll talk in more detail in
just a few moments about that.
But this isn't just Snowden's
own leaks of information.
Obviously, that
made those programs
that he leaked transparent,
but the government
fought back with
more transparency,
which was a bit of a surprise.
Now, they did this
in a tactical way
to try to defend themselves
against accusations.
These programs
were out of control
and didn't have any
privacy safeguards.
But I would argue
that this has created
a lasting change in the culture
of secrecy of the intelligence
community, although
a fragile one,
and there's a real danger
of going back to bad habits.
So a real revolution there.
An end to a domestic
bulk collection program--
in 2015, Congress
basically took this program
that I'd worked on
for many years that
was kept secret from
the American people,
and decided to end it.
It had not proved as
effective as we had thought,
and there was a better way
to collect telephone records.
That was a major reform
to the Patriot Act.
And reforms to the secret
Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court that
resulted from the reaction
to Snowden, including
appointing outside lawyers
to argue the other side in
cases that affected privacy.
But I think that the most
important change that
resulted from Snowden's decision
to leak classified information
in 2013 was a change to our
entire conception of privacy
that the government and the
intelligence community used.
For decades, privacy
meant Americans.
When I was in government,
when I told people
that I worked on privacy
and civil liberties issues,
the first thing that
came to their mind
was, well, how much
data about Americans
do we have in this program?
If it's a fair amount, then
we'll let Tim look at it.
If this is mainly a
foreign program, you know,
this really isn't something
for the privacy office.
Now we have rules to protect
the privacy of foreigners.
Now, these rules-- I don't
want to oversell them.
They're relatively modest.
But the fact that
there are rules at all
in a policy directive that
President Obama issued roughly
in 2014, implemented
a year later,
is really a revolution for
the intelligence community.
So what's the verdict here?
Well, I think the
verdict is obvious.
Snowden's way was
much more damaging,
but it was also
much more effective
than my way of working
inside the system.
So the question I want
to ask and I talk about
in the book is,
what are we going
to do with that information?
Can we do better than that?
Are we just going to wait
around for another 10 years
and hope that another
Snowden emerges
to tell us about
mass surveillance
programs in the future?
Or is there a way
to reform the system
so that people like
me on the inside
have a fighting chance to
ensure effective protections
of privacy without the need
for a set of massive leaks?
I'm going to go back
in time a little bit
to talk a little bit about the
birth of the mass surveillance
state.
And that's going to bring us
back to September 11, 2001.
A few weeks after
that terrible attack,
I was an ACLU lawyer
in Washington,
and we were gathered on
the steps of the Capitol,
trying to persuade lawmakers
as they walked over
to vote for the Patriot Act, a
new anti-terrorism surveillance
law, that they really ought to
stop and think about what they
were doing, that the powers
that they were voting to give
the government had not
been fully thought through,
and that we needed to take
some time to figure out
how to better protect our
country while still preserving
privacy and civil liberties.
We didn't get much of a hearing.
The law passed overwhelmingly.
Both parties voted
overwhelmingly for it.
And back in the
office, our director,
Laura Murphy, who you can
see here in this slide,
was asking the question, are
we becoming a surveillance
society?
And it was a real
question that we, frankly,
didn't know the answer to.
Because we didn't know
how the government
was planning to
use its new powers.
So we got together
with other groups
to try to imagine
hypothetical scenarios that
would illustrate the dangers
of these new spying powers.
One of the examples
we used was based
on a real historical example,
when the FBI had used earlier
surveillance powers to go and
try to get people's library
records to uncover
people that might
be susceptible to
becoming radicalized
and spying for the Soviet Union.
So we worked with librarians
to call attention to the fact
that under the Patriot Act,
there were these broad powers
to get records, any
kinds of records,
in order to prevent terrorism.
Now, the government at that time
kind of ridiculed these fears.
Bush's Attorney,
General John Ashcroft,
said that we were
trying to scare people
with phantoms of lost liberty--
phantoms of lost liberty.
And I remember thinking
a little bit, you know,
actually, the attorney
general has a point.
We don't know how
these surveillance
powers are being used.
And so we were, in a
sense, fighting phantoms.
In 2005 and 2006, I
had an opportunity
to go inside the
surveillance state.
The intelligence community
was being reorganized in order
to better share
information, and a lot
of the reason it was
being reorganized
was to better share
information that
was domestic with
was foreign about
terrorist organizations.
And so there are civil liberties
concerns, privacy concerns
with doing that.
When they created the
new director of National
Intelligence to be the head
of the intelligence community,
we had a victory at the
ACLU and other groups,
because we created, in that
office, a privacy official that
would report directly to
the head of the intelligence
community.
And much to my surprise, they
looked to me and said, Tim,
would you like to
come work for us
and be the second
employee of this privacy
office, the first deputy for
civil liberties in the history
of the intelligence community?
And I thought long
and hard about this.
This is 2006.
My first interview for
the job, by the way,
at the headquarters of the old
CIA building in Washington,
was the same day that the
New York Times broke a story
about Bush bypassing the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act
and authorizing
warrantless wiretapping.
So this gave me a
little pause as to going
into the Bush Administration.
But I decided I really just
couldn't resist the chance
to find out about
all these phantoms
that we have been
fighting, and see
if I could make a
difference on the inside.
What did I learn?
Well, I learned that there
had been a transformation
in our intelligence apparatus.
And it wasn't just about
international terrorism
or Al-Qaeda or 9/11.
It was also about the internet
and the transformation
of technology over the
past couple of decades.
The map that you
see up there shows
what the NSA, at the time,
was calling its home field
advantage.
Look at all that data flowing
right through the United
States of America.
And yet, our laws
basically provided
court review and
protections for this data,
based on the theory
that this was
potentially domestic
surveillance, even if the data
belonged to foreign people.
But it turns out there were
some loopholes and weaknesses
in the way those laws worked,
and that's because of the way
the Supreme Court
had interpreted
the Fourth Amendment.
Foreign people outside
the United States,
the Supreme Court
had said, they don't
have rights under the Fourth
Amendment to the Constitution.
And also, data that isn't
the content of communication,
even if you're an American,
if the data is not
the content of
communication, if it's only
the metadata, that also
doesn't have Fourth Amendment
protection.
So using creative lawyering,
the Bush Administration
helped to create an innovative
series of mass surveillance
programs that took advantage
of this home field advantage.
Bulk collection
of metadata-- that
means collecting all
of it, analyzing it
for patterns that
would hopefully
uncover terrorist groups.
And then going after the
content of communications
where the target,
the direct target
is someone who's a foreign
person outside the United
States, but they
might be incidentally,
as we say, talking to Americans.
So that was the home field
advantage of the NSA.
Our job, really, was to
take these programs that
started very quickly after
9/11 in enormous secrecy,
bypassing altogether the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance
Court that's supposed to review
this kind of data gathering,
and putting that under
checks and balances.
But we did it almost
entirely in secret.
Now, there was that leak
that I told you about,
the Bush Warrantless
Wiretapping Program,
but major parts of the
program remained secret
while we were in the process
of institutionalizing it
under all three
branches of government.
Along comes Obama in 2008.
We all remember that hopeful
period in American history.
And one of the things he
did during his campaign
was to promise a review of
all NSA surveillance programs.
It's part of a broader reset
of the whole war on terror.
He said, of course we
need to fight terrorism.
But we shouldn't sacrifice our
rights and liberties to do so.
And his rhetoric was
inspiring to many.
However, some people
might have noticed
that in the summer of 2008
he had voted to approve
a broad NSA surveillance law.
Now, he did it
very thoughtfully,
as we would expect from the
former constitutional law
professor, with a long
post to his supporters
who were disappointed,
explaining why he did that.
And a lot of it had to do with
his main concern being checks
and balances, saying that
President Bush had put too
much power on the president.
He thought Congress should
authorize these programs,
courts should look
at them, and that's
why he was voting for this law.
Now at this time, major parts
of the program, as I mentioned,
were still secret.
We knew about monitoring
international telephone calls.
That's what Obama had
voted for in 2008.
We didn't know-- and when I say
"we," I actually don't mean we.
I mean you.
You didn't know about bulk
collection of metadata.
I had learned about it
a few years earlier.
Now when Obama
comes into office,
I get a wonderful opportunity
to go to the White House
to serve as the first privacy
official in the National
Security Council.
And I was hopeful that we would
be able to make broader changes
than we had made
under President Bush,
that we'd be able to
say, OK, we've put
these programs under the court.
We briefed them to Congress.
Now let's have a
conversation about privacy.
That never really happened.
Obama was briefed on
the program, said, well,
if the Court's OK with
them, I'm OK with them.
Fast forward to 2013.
I'm beginning to wrap up
my government service,
looking at working for Brown.
Meanwhile, Mr.
Snowden is thinking
about doing something
much more dramatic
in leaving the government.
And along comes my former
boss, Jim Klapper, the Director
of National Intelligence, in
an open hearing in the Senate,
and he's asked a question
by Senator Ron Wyden.
He says, does the
NSA collect records
on millions or hundreds
of millions of Americans?
Now, this is a very
loaded question.
And it's a question that
Senator Wyden already
knows the answer to.
He's been briefed
on the programs.
So has everyone else on
the intelligence committee.
And in fact, that was part
of the checks and balances
that we had worked on.
But Wyden is upset.
He can't get anyone's
attention, which makes sense.
It's a secret program.
So he decides to
grill the director
of National
Intelligence in public,
asking him a tough question.
Now, of course, this
puts General Klapper
in a rather difficult position.
He could answer the
question honestly
and say, well, Senator, as
you know, the answer is yes.
That would reveal the
existence of the program.
He could also say, I can neither
confirm nor deny whether or not
the NSA collects
hundreds of millions
of records of Americans.
That would also kind of imply
that the answer is yes--
one of the problems with
the neither confirm nor deny
language.
So instead he says,
no, sir, not wittingly.
Now, as we all know,
that was not true.
There are a variety of
arguments as to exactly
what was in Klapper's mind.
Only Klapper knows the
answer to that question.
I talk about in the book the way
in which, in a very unique way,
this one person was whipsawed
by competing obligations.
Obviously, he has an
obligation to tell
the truth and the whole
truth in sworn testimony.
But he also has the
direct obligation
to keep the government secrets.
Because the government had
decided to keep this secret,
that put him in the tough
spot that he was in.
Well, in just a
couple of months,
the first stories start to
appear from Snowden's trove
of documents.
And we find out that
the truth was not,
no, sir, not wittingly.
The truth was, yes we scan.
It turns out, yes, we do have
programs of mass surveillance
that affect millions
and hundreds of millions
of Americans.
So just to summarize
very briefly,
what are the things that
we learned from Snowden?
Well, we learned
of the existence
of this domestic bulk
collection program
of telephone records, the orders
to the telephone companies.
We learned about
internet surveillance,
programs called upstream
collection and PRISM,
also called down
stream collection.
And that's the program
involving looking
at foreign communications,
but incidentally,
looks at Americans
who are communicating
with those foreign targets.
That's the content program.
But we learn a lot more.
We learn about many
other NSA programs
that undermine the
security of communications
around the world.
Now, in a way, this is
not really a surprise.
This is what the
NSA's job is, is
to break into communications.
It's just that a lot of people
didn't know how good they
were at their job.
So maybe President Obama has
encouraged a lot of people
to understand that
their agencies actually
have a lot of dedicated
public servants
that do their job
really, really well,
like breaking into
communications.
But we hadn't had
a public debate
about how this was
affecting the privacy
and security of the whole
world's communications,
and that's because
of excessive secrecy.
So what happened as a result?
Well, we ended up with
an intelligence community
that reacted in a
way that is unusual.
The normal reaction is,
we don't comment on leaks
of classified information.
We don't confirm programs.
We don't talk about it.
This didn't work.
There was just too much
political heat for Jim Klapper
to be able to go
out there and say,
I'm not going to
comment on whether I
was lying to the Senate
a couple of months ago.
I'm not going to comment on all
these massive stories that's
got everybody up in arms.
So they decided to do
the opposite, which
is to release thousands
of pages of documents.
A lot of people don't know
this, but by March of 2014,
the government had released
double the documents about NSA
surveillance that had been
leaked by Edward Snowden,
on its own transparency website
called IC on the Record.
Now, these documents were
mostly orders and rules
about how this surveillance
could be conducted,
what the privacy
oversight was, things
that I'd worked on for years.
Many of them were opinions
of the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court, redacted
in some places, but really,
tremendous amount
of detail that we
learned from those documents.
And then going forward,
issuing an annual intelligence
transparency report with
details that the government had
for decades argued
were classified, now
made public on an annual basis.
But it went beyond transparency.
It also resulted in
significant accountability
that actually, I would argue,
strengthened intelligence.
Now this is my great image.
Stole it from the Electronic
Frontier Foundation, EFF,
all your data.
I actually think that
this may, in some ways,
not do exactly what the EFF
wants, because it kind of makes
the NSA look pretty cool.
Anyway, Congress
in 2015 was looking
at whether to renew the
legal authority, the Patriot
Act, that allows them to collect
in bulk all this metadata.
And essentially, they
decided, no, we're
going to reform the program.
A major reason for that
is that a privacy board
reviewed, in detail, the
government's claims about how
this had helped with
terrorist attacks,
and found that in each
of those instances,
this massive program
of bulk collection
had actually provided no
unique value to the government.
Now, this is an area where
I felt quite embarrassed.
I had worked for years on
oversight of this program
to make sure that people
were obeying the privacy
rules around access
to this bulk database.
I had been told that there was
important terrorist incidents
in which this bulk
database had been used,
and I basically accepted
that at face value.
And after the Snowden
revelations came out,
I even defended them on
National Public Radio and said,
you know, they've helped
to stop a certain number
of terrorist attacks.
When this board
looked in more detail,
they found that, in fact, the
government had had that data
from other sources.
So it wasn't as valuable
as we had thought.
That was an important reason
Congress ended that program.
Now, I say ended, but it's
important to understand,
they ended the bulk collection
part of the program.
The NSA analysts still were
given access to this metadata
but on a case by case basis.
It turns out that that made
the program more effective.
It gave them access to
more, rather than less,
relevant data.
Because without the
secrecy and the logistics
of having to collect
all the data,
they could look at
smaller providers.
They could get a
richer source of data
when they weren't
collecting all of it.
So that's an important and
valuable lesson about reform.
I also talked a little bit
about the secret court.
The secret court really
is a genuine federal court
with judges that are approved by
the Senate, lifetime of tenure.
They are not quite
the rubber stamp
that people think
they are, but they
get skewed by the existence of
a one sided argument process,
which we saw very much after
the Snowden revelations had
distorted the law.
In the Freedom Act, one of
the important provisions
in that law basically
says when there
is an important legal
issue, the court
should appoint another lawyer
to argue the other side
of that legal issue.
Interesting idea.
Something I learned
in law school,
tends to strengthen the
quality of judicial decisions.
I think it's already done that.
I think we need to
go a lot further
with reforming the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance
Court.
It was set up to review wiretap
applications, basically to say,
is there probable cause that
you are spying for the Russians,
that you are part of Al-Qaeda?
That's a fairly
straightforward decision
that judges make every day.
Now it's overseeing
vast programs
of transnational surveillance.
And to have just a federal
judge and a tiny staff
perform that function,
to me, is not going
to provide effective oversight.
I argue that instead of
just bringing in lawyers,
we also need to bring in
technologists to help the FISA
Court.
There's been a number of
incidents in which the FISA
Court has reviewed
NSA programs where
the NSA made major
mistakes in how
they implemented the programs.
And for the most
part, these were
mistakes involving what I call
failed lawyer technologist
communication.
The lawyer says, we've
been authorized to do this,
the technologist hears
something different.
The technologist comes
back later and says,
this is how it works.
The lawyer says, oh
my god, I've been
lying to the FISA
Court for two years
because I didn't realize
we were getting this data.
So having technologists in
the FISA Court would help.
But the most lasting
challenge was really
something that
came as a result--
I'd like to say it's because
of our country's strong support
for the human rights of
everyone around the world,
including the right
to privacy, but that's
really not the reason.
After the Snowden
revelations, people
like me, former
intelligence officials
and current
intelligence officials,
went out there and said, you
have nothing to worry about.
We have strong protections
for the privacy of Americans.
A lot of companies
in Silicon Valley
said, please stop
talking about that.
This is hurting our business.
We have customers and
users around the world.
We don't want them all
migrating to other services.
You have to do something to
reassure the rest of the world
that you care about
their privacy, too.
This photo here
is from a meeting
that President Obama had with
ex-CEOs in December of 2013.
You may recognize the
man he's talking to.
So Google, Facebook,
Yahoo, others,
they have a lot of political
power in a way that voters
in Germany and Brazil don't.
And that caused the
administration to say,
we have to do
something about this.
So they issued something called
Presidential Policy Directive
28.
That flows trippingly
off the tongue.
I've been accused
sometimes of being
a wonk on surveillance issues.
I won't quiz you after
this talk about what
is Presidential Policy Directive
28 or FISA Section 702,
but this is important.
This policy directive
basically laid down
a marker for the
intelligence community saying
that foreign privacy
matters, that there
have to be rules to protect
the personal information that
is collected by
agencies like the NSA
in these bulk
collection programs.
And this particular
quote, to me,
sums it up, that everyone has
to be treated with dignity
and respect regardless
of their nationality
or wherever they might
reside, and all persons
have legitimate
privacy interests
in the handling of their
personal information.
This was a revolutionary concept
for the intelligence community.
What do you mean all persons?
What about-- I thought
it was just Americans.
I though it was just US persons.
Now I have to worry
about everybody else?
So here's an area where I
don't think we've done enough
on surveillance reform.
And actually, in many of these
areas we haven't done enough.
And that has to do
with what I call
in the book,
technological magic.
For years, the
intelligence community
had been studying how to
use encryption and privacy
preserving technologies
to extract information
from massive datasets
with real privacy
guarantees for all the
people's information
that are in that data set.
We learned after some of
the Snowden revelations
that, yeah, the NSA vacuums up
huge quantities of information.
Usually they have some
purpose for doing this other
than looking at
everybody's information,
and they use people
like me, lawyers,
to try to enforce policy
constraints on the analysts.
And that can be fragile.
You know, people can violate
those policy constraints.
Math is a lot less
fragile when it comes
to those kind of guarantees.
So this is a picture of
[INAUDIBLE] my colleague
at Brown University,
who has pioneered
many of these encrypted
search techniques.
We haven't implemented them.
You know, we're studying them.
We're continuing to study them.
Here it is, 2017, four
years after Snowden.
So this is an area where
we have a lot of work
to do when it comes to
surveillance reform.
I want to close thinking
about the danger of abuse
of these mass
surveillance capabilities.
When Ed Snowden was asked
in his first interview
in this hotel in Hong Kong,
well, why are you doing this?
Why are you revealing all
of these secret programs
and putting yourself in such
risk when you haven't really
shown us examples of the kind
of domestic political abuse
of surveillance that
we'd seen in the past?
We didn't have examples from
Edward Snowden of, you know,
Obama using
surveillance authority
to go after his
political opponents
in order to discover gossip.
We didn't have those examples
from the Bush Administration,
either.
And what he said to
that was, well, we're
not always going to have
enlightened leaders,
essentially.
He's worried about building
an architecture of oppression
in which it's very fragile.
Some day, he said, someone
else will be elected,
and they'll flip the
switch, and this apparatus
could be turned against us.
Well, in 2016 a lot of
people in my old community
in the national security
world were very worried
that that person had been found,
and had just been elected.
During the campaign-- we all
know about Donald Trump's
rhetoric during the
campaign and after that
seemed to denigrate important
constitutional liberties
and rights, respect for
religious minorities,
and just the kind of
open promises of abuse
of civil liberties
we'd really never seen
before from any president, even
presidents like Richard Nixon
hadn't gone out
there and bragged
about the kinds of abuses
that they wanted to engage in.
And because of that,
people may not even
have noticed that he actually
endorsed warrantless searches
in his campaign.
There is an interview
in which Donald Trump
is asked what he's going to do
about the dangers of terrorism.
He says, I want surveillance.
I want surveillance of
the Muslim community.
And yes, warrantless
surveillance
might be necessary.
Now, of course, also
the dangers of abuse
are not just something
Trump might engage in.
There's something that Trump
supporters have suddenly
woken up and discovered in
their fears of the deep state.
A few months ago,
Donald Trump himself
discovered the dangers
of surveillance abuse,
tweeting out, "Terrible!
I just found out that
Obama had my 'wires tapped'
in Trump Tower."
Now, this shows a shocking
ignorance of the fact
that no president under our laws
can tap the wires of someone
else without--
I was about to say
without their consent--
without permission
from the FISA court.
But it also shows
perhaps an opportunity
among political
opportunity where
people who may fear
Trump and his potential
for abusing our
civil liberties could
unite with those who support
him and are worried about people
in the intelligence community
abusing their power to go
after him and his supporters.
I want to close by talking a
little bit about what should we
do going forward.
You know, part of
the reason I called
the book "Beyond
Snowden" was to say
that we've had a debate about
Snowden that has focused often
on him and what should
we do about him.
And I have said that
because of the reforms
that his disclosures
caused, my view is
that he should be
pardoned, even though I
do agree that they also
caused significant damage
to national security.
But I think more
importantly than that
is to reform our
surveillance apparatus.
So I've offered a
detailed and rich list
of policy recommendations
near the end,
boiling them down a bit.
We need even more transparency
about how our surveillance
system works.
We need laws that respect
everyone's privacy,
not just the privacy
of Americans,
and we need to do a lot more
to use the magic of crypto
and other technology
that can help us obtain
the data we want without
obtaining the data
that we don't want.
Taken together, I
would say that we
need a serious
overhaul of how we
protect privacy and civil
liberties in the age
of mass surveillance.
And this puts me sort of
right smack in the middle,
on the very, very far edge
of the national security
community, which finds
many of my recommendations
unworkable, but sometimes
on the other side
of civil libertarians who
tell me, Tim, you know,
we just need to junk
all these programs.
We're never going to make
them safe for democracy.
And my view on that is
simply that the programs
are, in some cases, very
useful for national security.
And one thing we
learned from the debate
is that the public,
for the most part,
wants the intelligence
community to have these robots
capabilities.
They just want more oversight.
And so that's what I've
tried to do in the book,
is tell us how we can do that.
So thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: So in
addition to data being
used for political
purposes, what
other major concerns should
we have, as Americans,
for our data being in
the hands of the NSA?
TIMOTHY EDGAR: Well, I
think abuse of our data
is something we've
seen does happen.
It certainly
happened in the past.
And it could be used for
a variety of bad reasons.
It could be used by an
unscrupulous politician
to try to leak
damaging information
for political purposes.
It could be used to
intimidate a whistleblower.
It could be used just for
overbroad invasion of privacy.
When a program is
set up, in order
to safeguard national
security, there
can sometimes be mission
creep, where it then
is used for a broader societal
interest, law enforcement,
and so forth.
So I think that
the real point is
that we are still very early in
the 21st century when it comes
to grappling with how
do we protect ourselves
in this age of mass data
and of mass surveillance.
And my argument is that our
laws have to reflect that.
We can't just be content
with a law that says, well,
if you want to get the
content of my telephone calls,
or the content of
my email messages,
you're going to need a
secret court warrant.
What about all my metadata?
What about all
that communications
that you have of me talking
with people outside the country?
I worry about that, too.
AUDIENCE: What can you
share about the research
into blockchain or smart
contract technologies
to improve transparency
and privacy
and maintain a level
of surveillance?
TIMOTHY EDGAR: Well, both
of those technologies
are very promising, and
they show different ways
in which we might be able
to use new and innovative
technologies.
For blockchain, I guess the
area that I think of immediately
is audit.
I think about the possibility
of having a way of auditing how
people are using data.
But one of the
ironies of our failure
to employ some of these
technical approaches
in our efforts to protect
privacy and civil liberties
from mass surveillance
is that much
of the research into of
these technologies, including
blockchain, including
encrypted search,
was funded by the
government itself,
in some cases by the
intelligence community.
And yet we still haven't
really come to grips
with how do we deploy these
technologies at the scale
that an agency like
the NSA would use,
despite the fact that we've
made real breakthroughs,
as I discuss in the
book, in using them.
I would need to give it a
little bit more thought,
but I think that's exactly the
conversation that we should
be having, is getting
people like the people
here at Google together with
people from the intelligence
community, and exchanging
ideas about here's
the tools and tactics
and techniques
that we have that are really
interesting crypto techniques.
What are your needs?
What are you trying
to extract from data?
How are you trying to
audit against misuse,
those kinds of things?
We had some early meetings
when I joined the ODNI
more than a decade ago, and they
funded some research programs.
But we haven't done
enough to transform that
into reality of deploying
these technologies.
AUDIENCE: Hi,
thanks for the talk.
Really interesting.
This is a really
difficult question to ask,
and you know, I want
to balance it and word
it correctly, given
that, you know, I
knew what it felt like on 9/11.
I remember that so clearly.
I lived in Israel
for a while and had
my own fair share
of situations there
that made me worry about
terrorism and threats to me
or my family's life
and things like that.
But a lot of analysis has
been done surrounding,
like, the value of
a human life, in how
the government values that.
And people have done
that with the Department
of Transportation, for example.
How much money is invested to
making our highways safe so
that we can protect the people
who use them, et cetera.
And people have done this a lot.
It's not an exact science
or anything like that,
but given how big the security
state is, really, in the United
States, and given that
you've kind of been there
and you've seen
what it can prevent,
what it can't prevent--
you've had your fair share
of knowledge of that--
what are your thoughts on that?
I mean, how important do you
think it is to focus on this?
Are we over invested?
Are we under-invested given how
much could happen if we never
had these protections in place?
Also, the fact that
there are some costs
associated with that.
This surveillance
can really ruin faith
in technology that actually
could protect people
against financial
crime and things
like that, because now
suddenly people don't trust
giving their information away,
where it actually might protect
them from things that
are more likely to happen
than terrorism.
So yeah, it's a
complicated question
and I hope it makes sense.
TIMOTHY EDGAR: No,
I think it does.
And the question
really comes down to,
have we overreacted to
the risk of terrorism?
I think most people would say
that we have in certain ways
overreacted.
I think in 2017
it looks different
than it did on the
morning after 9/11.
We had a lot of experiencing
counter terrorism.
And I think what I would
suggest is that we simply
look a lot more clear-eyed at
the question of effectiveness.
So two examples-- I talked to
you about the bulk collection
of telephone records,
and how that program--
we spent a lot of
time putting together
the legal rules that should
govern access to the database,
and ways to protect privacy.
But this was a massive
database of call records
which clearly posed
a risk to privacy.
And we had some anecdotal
information, basically,
about how it had been
used to prevent terrorism.
But when that was put to
the test by the Privacy
and Civil Liberties Oversight
Board, after the Snowden
revelations, the conclusion
was, actually, this
was not necessary.
This whole program that
had been in existence
for more than a decade did
not provide unique value
in preventing any
terrorist incidents.
Even though it had been used
in some terrorism cases,
they already had that data.
Now you contrast that to the
PRISM and Upstream collection
programs, which Congress is
debating right now this fall,
and the privacy board basically
came to the opposite conclusion
and said, of course this program
has privacy implications,
but we've examined carefully the
effectiveness of the program,
at least in terms of
the terrorist incidents
the government says
it has prevented,
we've looked at each
case, and yes, it
has provided valuable and
unique contribution to help head
off those terrorist attacks.
Now, you could, I suppose,
do some actuarial calculation
and say, well, if those
attacks had happened,
and a certain number
of people had died,
this would be the damage.
And then we have
to somehow assign
a value to the
privacy that has been
invaded by having the program.
I wouldn't go that far.
I think it's already
a step forward
just to ask the basic
question, did it work at all?
We've seen that we can get a lot
more privacy simply by asking
that question, even if we put
infinite value on human life
and we say, you know,
preventing a terrorist attack
is worth these
kinds of programs.
If it's not actually
doing that at all,
then the question
becomes a lot easier.
AUDIENCE: If one studies
the terrorism literature,
the purpose of terrorism
is to terrorize
and to cause the empire
to overreact, and thus
internally destroy itself.
That's in all the writings.
And we play right into
the hands of the--
and so terrorism accomplishes
what they want, unfortunately.
So is there any
recognition that they're
playing into the hands of the
terrorists by overreacting?
TIMOTHY EDGAR: That's
a great question.
I would say this comes back
a little bit to the Trump
Administration.
You know, Trump is--
the rhetoric that he
used in the campaign
gave a lot of people
who were experienced
in the national security
world a lot of fear
that we would have these kinds
of massive overreactions,
and that we would play into
the hands of terrorist groups
that were promoting a narrative
of a clash of civilizations.
And we've seen with the
travel ban and other policies
that President Trump
has, in fact, done that.
At the same time, you have a
permanent national security
establishment that has learned
some lessons, I would argue,
over the past decade and
a half or more since 9/11,
the policy changes that
were made by the Obama
administration to protect the
privacy interests of foreigners
and their personal information--
that's Presidential Policy
Directive 28--
a lot of my former
colleagues said, well,
that's out the window.
Trump doesn't care
about foreigners.
He's America first.
So day one, you know, we'll
see that directive rescinded.
It hasn't been.
It hasn't been, and in
fact, has been reaffirmed
by the new director of
National Intelligence
on very pragmatic grounds,
which is that we need
the support of many
other countries
in our intelligence and our
intelligence activities.
I would also caution,
even though we've
been talking a lot
about terrorism,
the intelligence apparatus
is not just about terrorism.
It's about broad
foreign policy interests
of a very powerful
country, the United States.
And that's another
reason, I think,
that the reaction to
the Snowden revelations
was different than we've seen
to other spying programs that
were more clearly
focused on terrorism.
It was pretty clear that
if the NSA is spying
on the chancellor
of Germany, it's
not because they suspect that
the chancellor of Germany
is a terrorist.
There are foreign policy
interests involved
in surveillance programs.
So that's an important
conversation to have.
My view is that the
calculation is different
when you're talking about
broad intelligence purposes,
and that there are some mass
surveillance capabilities
that we should not be using
for those broader intelligence
objectives.
We should only be using
them for security threats
like terrorism.
So that would be my
recommendation to Congress
when it comes to
PRISM and Upstream,
is do we really need to be
using this program for broader
foreign policy interests, as
opposed to for the terrorists
purposes that
Congress, you know,
was thinking about when
they passed that law?
AUDIENCE: I think
one last question--
how do we, as citizens, forward
the cause of civil liberties?
TIMOTHY EDGAR: It's
a great question.
Well, I know that some
of the folks in this room
may know that Senator
Dianne Feinstein is
an important leader on
intelligence issues.
She is also not, I would say,
a reliable civil libertarian,
to put it mildly.
So pressure on Senator Feinstein
from people in California
will have an impact on the
debate Congress is having right
now on Prism and Upstream.
Also, educating people on
how the technology works.
This is an important
audience here at Google
that can look at some of the
programs I'm talking about
and have an intelligent
conversation about IP addresses
and content of communications
and how selectors are used,
taking advantage of that
transparency I talk about.
There's just an enormous
amount of information
that used to be classified
at the top secret level, when
I worked in government, that has
been declassified and released
about how much of this
surveillance works.
But it's still impenetrable
to a lot of people.
One reason I wrote
the book is to make
it understandable
to ordinary people.
It's a reason that I
use ordinary words,
like mass surveillance
instead of jargon
that the intelligence
agencies like, like collection
of signals intelligence
under executive order, 12
triple three.
And this has caused some
of my former colleagues
to say, hey, this is
scary language, Tim.
You know, you're scaring people.
You should tell them about all
of our privacy protections.
But my view is it's important to
use plain and ordinary language
about what the
government is up to.
If we agree with
what they're doing
and we think the protections
are good enough, then so be it.
But we shouldn't be having
a conversation that's
clouded in euphemisms, like
signals intelligence instead
of mass surveillance.
So you all here in
the tech community
can help illuminate these
issues for the public.
And organizations
like EFF and ACLU
are always looking for
people who can help them out.
In fact, the ACLU of
northern California
has an open position.
I don't necessarily want
to recruit everybody here
away from Google, but
for a technologist.
And whether you end up
doing like what I did
and working as an activist,
or whether you just
want to join with the
group and help them out,
I just think that the
talent in this room
could be so helpful to
those kinds of groups
as they advocate for
privacy and civil liberties.
And I would also encourage you
to look into government service
and to see what
you can do to make
a difference on the inside.
I am very proud of the
service I did, as limited
as some of my victories were.
And having people who understand
how the internet works
and how technology works
will help the lawyers
and the officials ask the right
questions, which they often
haven't asked in the past.
DAVID: Well, thank you, Tim.
Let's give him one
more round of applause.